is it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a m stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that on TV on radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
TV tonight on Pi Morgan uncensored from
here in Los Angeles I sit down again
with George Santos the disgraced us
congressman who less than a year ago
admitted to me was a terrible liar did
you not think people would find this out
I've been a terrible liar those lies
came back to haunt him the expulsion of
the gentleman from New York Mr Santos
he's now been thrown out of Congress one
of only six people in history in the
United States and he's facing 2 three
criminal charges I'm not saying I'm an
innocent little flower nobody's an
innocent little flower will he go to
prison it's a long barrel to be looking
down is he sorry and I'm asking
everybody to please give me a second
chance what happened to George Santos I
just don't get the constant lying for no
[Music]
reason George so it's been nearly a year
incredibly since we did that now
Infamous interview in New York a lot has
happened to you in that time I was
struck by a tweet as he flew into Los
Angeles to do this interview where he
said just landed at LAX and as I'm deing
I had a gentleman come up to me and
thank me for my service in
Congress now because it's George Santos
I have to ask you first did that happen
yes it did
yes do you think you deserve to have
that kind of response from the public
you know I invite all of folks in the
media up here to come back home with me
and ask the people yourselves don't
don't believe me you don't need to
believe me right I've been discredited
for an entire year in the media it
doesn't matter how much I've admitted to
what I I where my shortcomings were and
where I did commit I was less than
truthful right but well last time you
admitted you were a terrible lie my
point so
the reality is is I I invite folks to
come into to my hometown and take a look
for yourself I am not in the same
predicament that the media has propelled
for the last year this is a very common
response I've received there's a sense
of outrage back home uh after the
expulsion really y there was pretty I'm
conservative peers people voted for a
conservative person for that District
after 26 years of Democrats and I went
in there and I was conservative through
and through the most conservative member
from the New York delegation nobody
voted for the George Santos yes they did
you actually are that's not true they
voted for the fake version you not true
they vot they vote they voted for the
principles the agenda the political
positions that I performed and and that
I did you not think any of the lies
matter no nobody voted for me based on
my resume and I've seen that actually
trend on Twitter for quite some time
people saying I didn't vote for his
resume I voted for his policies and
guess what he delivered on each and
every one of them I never broke a single
campaign promise a single one pierce do
you know how many politicians can say
that very few what did you actually
achieve though uh you know what it's
it's very hard to achieve anything where
nobody is give your main achievement as
a congressman my votes i' I I maintained
but what did you actually achieve well
like I said I was this guy's thanking
you for your service in Congress what
did you actually achieve thanking for me
I I that's a question for him right he
was sitting next to me what do you think
you achiev I think I achieved standing
standing my conservative ground I never
buckled I never I never bend it over to
the establishment or to said the liberal
mob in Congress I've always kept my it
was the liberal mob that got rid of you
no it was the liberal mob yes it was it
was actually a lot of Republican sure
but not a majority of them a minority of
Republicans along with every single
Democrat almost and you were the first
Republican Congress person ever to be
thrown out yes that's true ever that's
true there only ever been six Congress
people thrown out I'm the six right
there's only three were in the Civil War
yeah right who were confed two were
indicted and two at criminal convictions
I didn't have any and then well not yet
well unless you can tell the future well
no you're facing 23 federal charges and
I'm fighting them I'm fighting them
seriously but they're serious they're
serious yeah so I mean since I saw you
last in less than a year everything that
you were then has gone up in smoke you
accept that oh a lot has gone up in
smoke but I'm still here right it's
still relevant people still want to talk
to me they still want to hear what I
have to say do they oh they do you would
be having this interview if you if they
did it well I think you're a fascinating
person but mainly because of what's
happened to you in the last
year confirming people's belief that in
many ways you were one of the worst
people to ever be in Congress do you do
you understand why people think that I
disagree I didn't sell out my country I
didn't take a single vote that would put
a man or a woman in the front line of a
war I didn't vote for anything that
would further a globalist agenda I love
my voting record and I stand by it I
actually think I have one of the very
few voting records that somebody can
actually put their head in in bed and
sleep at night without worrying about
how far down the river they sto the
American people pierce you know when you
look at some of those records over there
people who voted to put us into endless
Wars nonsensical Wars because of
political vendettas that a president had
of his daddy's uncon UNC UNC nonc
concluded efforts in the Middle East or
whichever
way it is that they they they rationale
to put people at War I never had to take
that vote and I would have not voted to
put us at War quite frankly I I've I
drew a line in the sand that I said
enough Bloodshed of Americans enough
American treasure being literally blown
to smithin abroad I I I I support my
voting record and I think it's one much
better even though it's only 11 months
of a voting record it's better than
people who have been there 30 years
right but then in November 2023 a house
ethics report found
that you had blatantly stolen from your
campaign that's not true and exploited
every aspect of your house candidacy for
your own personal profit that's also not
true well that's what they found well
that's what they think that's what they
speculated they didn't come to a that
was a conclusion no that was not a
conclusion that ethics report was not a
conclusion it was an again it was on the
basis of that that the vote happened
that threw you out Pierce just look at
this their report is so so lambastic bad
Michael guess is such an AB failure of a
chairman of the Ethics Committee he has
his own issues with ethics himself I
don't think he knew ethics if it looked
at him in the face but would you it it I
do and in his report you think ethics
mean well give me a second let me
conclude this thought in his report he
says that I'm exonerated from any
accusation of sexual harassment towards
a potential staffer which was a blatant
false hit on me by somebody who just
wanted to infiltrate my staff and then
on his expulsion resolution he says that
I committed uh sexual assault against
that same idual which one is it Pierce
it's a contradiction that nobody can
understand it's so sloly that that
wasn't why you were thrown out well the
fact that it was contrarian to what was
in the report but was in the resolution
to expel me should just give you a
little glimpse of understanding how
sloppy the process was there was a there
was only one accepted predetermined
result and they didn't want to do the
full investigative report which would
have taken why your why would your own
fellow Republicans be party to throwing
you out if you're such an innocent
little flower I'm not saying I'm an
innocent little flower nobody's an
innocent little flower neither you are
neither I am none of those 434 members
in Congress right now are I'm saying
we're all human we all make mistakes we
all are flawed human beings and I
believe that fundamentally but the way
that this Witch Hunt of an Ethics
investigation on me was in Congress was
completely unethical it says a lot when
I have to say in sight that the doj has
been far better courteous and respectful
of the process that we're undergoing and
the Ethics Committee just completely
squandered them themselves the irony of
what you're saying is it they found of
an extensive investigation that it was
you that have been completely unethical
uh for example you spent campaign money
on Botox treatments luxury fashion
purchases trips to Atlantic City in Las
Vegas holidays in the Hamptons even your
own rent that's not true none of is true
no it's not as a political candidate we
travel all across the country to raise
funds Las Vegas Atlantic City Hamptons
am I the first politician with an
expenditure in the Hamptons with
fundraisers attached to it they're full
of crap it's baloney they just they they
just use buzzwords to get folks like you
in the media to be able to go up in arms
and say oh my God George Santos did this
and that and ABCD I don't care about
what you did well my point is I didn't
do any of that and they know Dam so when
they say you were frequently in debt had
an abysmal credit score relied on ever
growing wallet of highin credit cards to
fund your luxury spending habits is that
also untrue I I'm not abysmally in death
wasn't then am not now have always paid
all my credit cards off and the amount
and volume of credit cards I keep that's
just to show you that they're out of
touch with the American people every
single American is dwindling with highin
credit cards because of decisions
politicians like that make in Washington
DC I was no different I was no different
but is that shameful to have in mind
don't have abysmal credit like it's it's
it's baloney it's absolute from
the Ethics Committee because they're a
bunch of little Lords who have if you
look at the panel of the committee just
look at the committee for the whole
itself right and you look at the records
of all those people those people have
all been in politics their entire
careers they don't know what it's to be
a regular CI you claim to own multiple
properties and a luxury car a Maserati
is that true I'm sorry you claim to own
multiple I own a jaguar I don't own a
Maserati did you ever claim to own a
Maserati I I have not I own a Jaguar I
own the Mercedes in the past a Range
Rover but not a Mas why did you tell
your stuff campaign stuff you're to
Maserati uh I'd love to see that that
was in the report and I didn't even read
that part in the report that's not TR I
have a Jaguar I have I love my Jaguar
you never told one of your staff you had
a Maserati no not that I recall of I
always drove a Mercedes during the
campaign and then a Jaguar you used U to
pay credit card debt and make make
purchases from companies including
Hermes only fans and Sephora okay and
you did this from a company Redstone
which paid you at least $200,000 and you
use that money to then go on the
spending spree with those things is that
true okay no I'm I'm not going to go
into the details of this because it's
because it's it's such yeah but
hang on George you can't say that some
of it is and then when I ask
you a specific like that I'm not going
to talk about I'm going to go this way
I'm not going to continue to unpack what
I already did on the house of the United
States I call this out on the house
floor on debate of this expulsion it's
it's so misconstrued it's so twisted and
spun that report Pierce that report no
cop in America would bring it to a DA no
decent da no decent prosecutor would
look at this report and say this is a
legal finding report that is a political
spin assassination ATT you called the
committee the committee is f look not
even all of the members of the committee
voted to expel me you call them
unethical you said that it's all
they called Michael guest
unethical but specifically this company
Redstone that paid you at least
$200,000 did you use that money to pay
off credit card debt I've said purchase
things from hermes's only F I've already
said no you didn't I already said no yes
you didn't spend any of that money on
those things here's a here's a deal
pierce the way that they did this it was
designed to hurt me because they needed
a way to get me out I'm not here to hurt
you no I'm not saying you I'm tell
that's and I'm telling you the truth and
I'm defending myself I'm not going to
stop none of the findings they found the
true Pierce I provided them with all the
documents all the financials and then
they released my taxes all out in the
public which is something that I didn't
even give consent to like I lost all my
rights as an American citizen my my my
Hippa rights were violated my my privacy
rights were violated every single right
of mine was violated by the Ethics
Committee and nobody's talking about
that nobody nobody cares to talk about
the fact that my hippo rights are
violated my my privacy rights are
violated the Ethics Committee did a
number on me if I were like any other
regular politician matter of fact if I
was Michael guest I'd be sitting in a
corner crying and weeping but I'm not
Michael guest I have a backbone and I'm
not going to stand I'm not going to C to
to to to what they want to if you're so
innocent why are you facing 23 Federal
chares I'm going to go ahead and fight
that I'm not discussing my doj
proceedings on TV this is not where I'm
you the first to mention the do I I gave
a contrast but I'm not discussing the
process right but but you get my point
if you're as innocent as you're trying
to make out why would you be facing 24
23 federal charges which could carry a
punishment of 20 years in prison I guess
you'll see that once the process plays
out that's all I can say but you've
denied all these charges like I said I'm
playing the process out not getting into
the doj you have denied them as a matter
of fact yeah I pled not guilty but
you're aware of the severity of the
charges no very aware you know
conspiracy to commit offenses against
America wire fraud false statements
falsification of records and documents
aggravated identity theft access device
fraud unlawful monetary transactions
over $10,000 theft of public money these
are serious charges there serious
charges and I'm playing the process and
fighting them as I
go but if you've denied them all none of
them are true like I said Pierce I will
not be discussing an ounce of the doj
you've got to have considered this is
going to come up in September I think
your yep September your case right trial
sir if you're convicted you will likely
go to prison for a long time are you
prepared for that pierce like I said uh
it's a scary it's a scary thing to be
facing it's a it's a long barrel to be
looking down and of course uh uh like
any other human being I would be worried
scared and concerned but right now I'm
going through the process and I have
faith I have faith but in your Quiet
Moments away from the public George
Santos when you think about what may
happen that's that's a tough thing isn't
it it's not easy no it's it's definitely
not easy but we we go along with the
ride and you just got to take it on the
chin and take it like a champ and move
on life goes
on we're here for joining us you're with
talk TV on TV on radio online on your
smart speaker as well criminals to
useing XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
sport today we do it all sunak sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tories love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella brav she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fast or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so £40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin B
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a Liv if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan should
have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man M mous he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology a
party political broadcast on behalf of
the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer are your questions
are you prepared to call Hass a terror
group is it possible to have a rational
I've asked you two questions should Hass
stay imp power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that
[Music]
since we did our last interview
obviously I went through a lot of things
which people had said you were lying
about and you I've dispelled a lot of
them in the media afterwards and I was
able to get Vindicated on at least some
of them I'm going to go through them
just to just to bring us up to speed to
see where we are with all this right so
on schooling you said you attended the
prestigious Horus man School in New York
for six months the school said there was
no record record has that record emerged
were you there I'm sorry no you were
never there no why did you say you were
well the the at Horman there was an
enrollment there was you weren there I
was not there for various reasons but
you claimed you were that's fine yeah
and and I I'm just curious why I I
admitted afterwards that I was not yeah
I'm just curious why well it's a long
story Pierce uh is there a short version
no there isn't really isn't it just that
you lied no no it's not just that I lied
there's there's a longer version of it
try
me Pierce it's it's a long try meor it's
a long story I've got all day well so do
I does your camera does absolutely it
look get more film it has to do it has
to do with my parents getting getting me
a deal to enroll and then the whole
thing falling through and then just not
being able to afford it so it was an
enrollment and yeah but the lie was that
you said you went there yes yes yes I
didn't go there business education I've
already cleared that up with you and
with everyone else right so business
education we established in our
interview last time that you're claiming
to have got a degree in economics and
finance from Baro college and a masters
from New York University were both false
that hasn't changed right there's been
no that was false again no has not
changed you just made it up like we said
last time any any other reason that you
want to share or was just you made it up
no okay you've claimed on your resume
that you worked in Wall Street you then
said it wasn't written by you is what
you told me last time it was not but by
a staff you said to me you have plenty
of emails to prove you were
uncomfortable with that have you
produced those emails yes and what do
they establish it just establishes that
I'm not comfortable with the way the bio
was written and the way the CV was
written that's all that somebody was
inventing a Wall Street career for you
oh no no not inventing a Wall Street
career I worked in in finance and
capital markets for years let's
establish that between linkbridge
investers met Global and um uh Harbor
City even though Harbor City ended up
being defined after my departure the
reality is I did have the career I did
have the
relationships people like to say that I
never worked a day in my life that's a
line that runs ramp did you work in Wall
Street uh well in in in the sense of
Wall Street on Wall Street proper no in
that industry around surrounding Wall
Street
yes your Jewish An ancestry you always
claimed Jewish and Ukrainian anesty and
said your grandparents survived the
Holocaust and fled persecution when I
quizzed you about that in my last
interview you said you would battle this
to your grave and I will you said you'd
ordered four DNA kits and were waiting
on their return to confirm your ancestry
I have them have you used them they're
going to be using a documentary so
they're embargoed right so it's been
nearly a year since you said you were
going to do that well I decided to do it
in my own terms and they're they're it's
getting done and you believe that DNA
test will prove that you are I know it
will I know it
will I know it will and I'm looking very
much forward to
it your mystery marriage certificate you
said you'd show me once the camera
stopped rolling but you didn't can you
show me now is there a mar uh I I
probably have it but I'm not going to
show it to you camera can't show me not
on camera I'll show it to you after it
rolls just remind me yeah yep how long
have you been married since November 20
uh November 2021 this married to Matt is
his name who's Matt Matt Santos that's
his last name Matt Santos yep
I love that you guys are so intrigued
with my spouse well that because you'd
be married to women now you Mar I was
married to a woman now you're married to
a man it's interesting but is that is
that very unique at all uh no okay it's
not unique it's at all right you've just
been quite frankly you've just been very
slow in being forthcoming about it uh no
I'm not I've always said I was married
to a woman first I mean folks folks who
know me knew I was married the problem
is the media thought they knew me and
they just wanted to create outrage
nobody talks about that Obsession about
the media no politician you love being
news no politician has ever gone under
I've never met anyone other than Donald
Trump who loves being in the news you
good bad and ugly reasons than youever I
don't like being in the news but I've
learned one thing here's I've learned
one thing after Congress you don't like
being in the news I did not like it at
first now I've learned one thing now you
love it well of course it pays my bills
the
more actually you love it back then I
did not like it it was very off-putting
I when you run for office you're running
for office but I don't think you quite
comprehend everything else that comes
with it and all that lack of I guess
privacy you lose your privacy rights
essentially right so we talked about
your mother who I know you were very
close to um you doubled down in our
interview that she had died as a
consequence of 911 but there's still no
record of her ever working anywhere near
the Trade Center um no one's been able
to find it in fact quite the opposite
they found evidence of Visa app ation
showing she wasn't even in the country
at the time do you want to green card
holder visa application that doesn't and
she died 15 years later and there's no
evident she died of anything relating to
what happened on 911 well look so here's
your chance to clarify that's already
been clarified in the documentary coming
out later this year well you can't keep
saying you got put stuff in the
documentary but it is there and I can't
talk about it I have a contract on it
but is your position that your mother
still died as you see in documentary you
just answer the question I can't answer
it that's ridiculous I can't it's
embargoed in the do your new position is
I've got a documentary I can't well no
no not on everything I've been giving
you answers there's things that are
embargo to the documentary and I'm I'd
love for you to see it do do you accept
that if you'd invented that that would
be pretty awful anybody who would invent
something like that would be awful so if
you if you were constructed a story that
your mother died didn't construct Pierce
let's put it this way I would never
construct anything about my mother my
mother was my best friend my mother was
my favorite human being and the fact
that I have to see people write and the
vital around things the disgusting
things that people have called my mother
and the disgusting things that people
have said regarding mother I mean the
disgusting garbage on social media the
most heartless people live on social
media behind a screen and the fact that
I have to see look I don't want be fair
to Trolls but what I would say about the
criticism is that you initially implied
to people your mother died in 9911 and
was in the towers she was nowhere near
the towers she didn't work in the towers
she may not have even been in the
country your documentary May well reveal
the story about that but certainly there
no evidence that your mother had
anything to do with what happened on
9/11 you'll see you'll see it in the
documentary I promise
you promise you that the Pulse Nightclub
we talked about that again we did talk
about that um that you said you lost
four employees in the Pulse Nightclub
shooting can I can I clarify something
there when I say four employees not my
employees I didn't own the company and
the employees and and I I double on they
weren't hired they were in process we
the company had just moved to Orlando
was in a massive hiring spree and this
was the information given to me at the
time by the people up top in the company
and I maintained that position I have no
reason to infiltrate myself into a
disaster like that nilly Willy and the
great thing is the record show I was in
Orlando on that night I was in Orlando
that entire year matter of fact of 2016
um and it's it's just so frustrating
that people try to say he said he owned
the company I never said I owned the
company when I work for a company for
instance you work what whatever station
you work for whether it's Fox Nation or
Sky News you wear their shirt at least I
do and I say the company my company the
criticism is George that people think
that you've attached yourself to a lot
of very big moments in history whether
it's your grandparents at the Holocaust
whether it's your mother a N1 whether
it's a Pulse Nightclub mass shooting
that you have used these events to
promote yourself in some way as being
attached to these things to make
yourself look better that's how does
that make you look better because
they're saying that you were somehow
involved in some way that you're you
were the grandchild of Holocaust
Survivors you were the son of a of son
of a n Survivor and so on that when in
fact there's no evidence these things
are true hundreds of thousands of people
are associated to Holocaust
descendants how does that make anybody
look better well it was a tragedy yeah
but it's it's a story that that adds to
your compelling personal narrative
unless it's untrue here's the most
frustrating thing that happened to me
last year was me losing my voice that is
something I could never uh explain to
you how frustrating it is what you mean
losing your
voice my my my story was told by
everyone in the media all the Talking
Heads I never got you didn't lose your
voice oh I you you sure you didn't stop
yapping all year oh no that's not true
it is true that's not true I could Yap
all I want I can talk all I want but but
at the end of the day everyone in the
media had the final say I never got the
final say to anything nobody ever nobody
bothered to to do any real digging you
in our interview doubled down on your
denial you'd ever performed as a drag
queen despite pictures per as a drag
queen that one picture that one incident
in a carnival when I was 18 years old so
you did perform as a drag queen I did
not perform I dressed up once I was 18
years old come on Rudy Giuliani got
motorboated by Donald Trump and nobody
called him a dry Queen an assassination
attempt you said happened on you you
said that there been that is translation
well the Rachel mad show got the footage
of the podcast where he made this claim
translated it word for word you denied
you'd ever said that you'd had an
attempt on your life an assassination
attempt in fact the exact translation of
what you said on that podcast in Brazil
was we have already suffered an attempt
on my life an assassination attempt so
you did say that I did and I've suffered
many more afterwards last year
assassination attempts there's there is
a man in right now in trial or in the
process of whatever it is the doj is
doing in Florida for literally
conspiring and telling us leaving a
voicemail at my congressional office he
was going to kill me and my husband and
it was a serious you know why it was
serious a man had a rap sheet he had
time he served or whatever the case was
he left the explicit voicemail
and capital police acted on it and the
doj and the FBI there were some things
we didn't get around to I wanted to
clear up one was that you were a
Volleyball Champion you told a radio
show in 2020 you were a star volleyball
player at Baro College well we can all
know where that ended up right was that
true no I played volleyball in high
school definitely not in college right
were you at Baro college no so you
weren't there let alone star volleyball
all of it was invented yep why George oh
here's so the
H I got to tell you if I he said you
slayed Yale AR rook's volleyball team
well they did they actually did slay
Yale but I wasn't part of it Bar's
volleyball team didn't even play against
Yale in the period you claimed to have
been there they did they did so you were
claiming to be a volleyball star for a
college you never went to in a game
where you slay Yale even though they
didn't play Yale in that period every
single part of it was a Whopper pretty
much yeah unfortunately again why here's
the thing I don't really get about you
CU you're very charismatic you have a
lot of qualities I can see that but but
can you expl can you explain to people
why you have been such an habitual liar
often for no
reason Pierce it's it's deeply rooted in
the process of politics back in New York
I've said this so many
times oh if only I could some things and
sometimes I I look I'm not at the
liberty of speaking of on certain things
because again I I have an entire process
with the doj ahead of me so it'd be
stupid it'd be ill advisable and uh I
wouldn't do myself any favors but
there's some people think you have a
sort of mental disorder I don't have you
ever have you ever had any
treatment first of all I am not a
pathological liar second of all what you
think that means well somebody who's
lied for a living yeah you have but
that's not true so you're saying that
out of my 35 years of existence the the
stupidity of the last two years is going
to make up for the entire of my entirety
of my life I would say that the Litany
of lies you told when you decided to run
for office absolutely constitute
pathological
life we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know what I love about talk today we do
it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love of scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swear an o in
the police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong unexpected item
in bagging area I know are we only going
to be trusting sources like meta and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
Union Kevin oiv is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth this is talk
TV he's the world's best loved
jockey and probably the greatest of all
time Frankie Dori is adored by the royal
family and he's become racing royalty
himself but it hasn't always been a
smooth ride banned from a sport he loved
a plane crash that changed everything
the pilot was trapped and died Dorian
Cochran somehow scrambled free it's been
a journey through Triumph and real
resilience true sporting Champion
Frankie Dori from Los Angeles here's
Morgan un
Sensi
[Music]
when you self-reflect have you been able
to work out what it is about you which
made you lie so brazenly so often but
often for no real reason that anyone can
really work out other than you just lied
you know Pierce no there's there's
nothing I can say to that there must be
a
reason no really no for unfortunately no
but you you're sure it's not a mental
disorder it's not a mental disorder how
can how can you be certain okay well are
you willing to diagnose me here and now
no I'm just curious how do you know how
do you know it's not oh
Pierce life hasn't been pretty I'll put
it that way um and clearly
um the last two years were tough um
things that happened in the campaign I
could I could barely ever even attempt
to start explaining it so I I always
choose to just it is what it is you
actually came into Congress as a breath
of fresh air you had a big win you were
seen as an electoral big electoral force
a Powerhouse the Republicans was a
Powerhouse and you hit Congress you you
were the first openly gay Republican
Congressman with a 16 and a half Point
Victory Swing for a Biden seat so all of
this was great right you and yet you've
blown that whole thing up because it
turned out that you just had hold
Endless Lies and the question is
everyone wants to know and you've never
really answered is why and it's
fascinating to me that you just don't
have an answer or you don't want to give
me an answer no I I don't have an answer
for
you I really
don't something in your childhood
no nothing no nothing triggered this
no no
nothing you can't explain it no can't
explain
it can't explain it sorry Pierce it's
you'd have to apologize to me oh I I
think you probably you probably
apologize to the American people many
times and I continue to do that yeah I
don't think I mean saying sorry to the
American people I'm a terrible lie it's
fine all right what do you say to your
husband when he he must have asked you
about all this uh we we've had
conversations did he know about all the
lies or was he no he finding out by the
media he found out by the media and what
was his reaction um cuz he loves you he
married you obviously not positive but
uh you know we work our we work our way
through uh our personal stuff together
he's your husband he must have asked you
to explain
it we have uh had a year for the books
both of us uh with our lives being
turned inside out uh you need to
understand that everything that happened
to me affected my family uh my husband
my sisters my my parents everybody you
know my father my mother's past but um
it's it's it's been tough it believe it
or not it's been really tough to even
sit down and unpack any of it as have
you cried a lot in the lost you I'm an
emotional person I'm not scared of
saying that um crying is something that
I I
actually do a lot in private I don't
think anybody has ever seen me cry but
um it's
uh yeah I'm an emotional person very
emotional so it's it's not uncommon do
you still lie no I have no reason to I
think when did you decide to stop it's
not about stopping or when I decided to
start no it's it's about lying is stupid
period right and and I think we all know
that when you've lied on your scale when
you've been that dishonest about every
part of your life not every part you
keep saying every part of my life no not
pretty much you're so you're going to
Define my entire life my work and
education period that's all that's what
you're doing that's that's literally
what you're doing you're defying my
entire life based on two aspects of a
human's life which one would say is not
even 10% of a person's life right is
your entire life your work and your
education it's not you have family you
have friends you
have a plethora of experiences as a
human being so to say my entire life
that's broadly and it's
offensive it's really darn offensive I
can assure you there's so much more I
can offer not not just you and your
viewers but the world what like what you
ask I don't know you you need to ask
sell yourself if there's another side to
you I've sold myself I'm a good person
I'm the person that you can call at 3:00
in the morning if I I have friends who
have spoken to journalists I've helped
friends out of abusive relationships
I've have I've helped friends out of
literally being out in the street I I am
a good person I go out of my way I take
the clothes off my back quite literally
to help people you've been on cameos
just caus a lot of entertainment to
people people to try to go have you been
on there no you should join you'd be a
hit but your rat's gone down oh it went
so the peak it was
$500 and I what are you now 350 I'm
still top two how many how many requests
you get a week uh on a good week now
after the New Year's it's been one week
I've gotten about 35 or 40 something
like that they're still coming in
steadily I reduced them first of all the
reason I I jacked them up was to deter a
little bit of the volume and I still did
1,200 videos in that short spam of you
find that fulfilling or you just do it
for money well first of all I think it's
fun I enjoy the the the connection with
them and obviously I have my bills to
pay Pierce and and and if that's how I'm
going to facilitate pay my bills I mean
there's no shame in that it's honest
work or do you disagree no I think
you're perfectly entitled to do it okay
there's nothing unethical about doing
Camy I know lots of people on cam like I
said I think you should do it you'd be a
hit I'm sure I would I don't I don't
need to do it
well why not is it beneath you I just
think I can't think of anything I'd
rather less do this day come on can do
one here for videos I do them for free I
I mean I do them for free to tons do you
know how many people say like oh I can't
afford your what do you want me to say I
said them friends and family do you feel
George do you
feel even if you can't explain why you
lied so much do you feel now that it's
all blown up in your face do you feel a
sense of shame or not really uh a
terrible shame and I've I've displayed
that many times um but here's the thing
I have nothing to lose the truth will
set me free I am not going to say
anything I mean you know the irony of
that statement well yeah sure there's
irony there but here's the the truth
might set you free here's the here's I
mean actually in that one sentence might
well be the thing that sets you free
yeah here's actually from now on saying
I'm going to tell the truth well that's
what I've been doing and it's making a
lot of people uncomfortable so I
recently was wearing a pin that said
they were fools to set me free as in my
colleagues in Congress because I just
won't stop talking well some of the
things you say about Congress I think
have real validity right I mean true
Congress has passed fewer bills I think
in this stage of the administration
under Joe Biden than in history at this
stage when you look at Joe Biden and you
look at Donald Trump and they may be the
two that duke it out for the White House
both of them have got a pretty checked
history when it comes to veracity
do you think there's an irony there that
you've been thr you've been thrown out
of office for persistent lying Jo Biden
has been lying since before I was born
Joe Biden was lying in his first
presidential campaign Joe Biden is a
prolific liar Donald Trump I don't I
don't understand what the obsession is
with his lies tell me one lie that
Donald Trump has said that is is even
comes close to Joe Biden give me one I
saying he had nothing to do with January
6th right he
didn't he didn't I was there I was at
the ellipse he didn't he was still
speaking I was second or third row at
the ellipse in a muddy pit of cold mud
he was still speaking and there were
people already in their own valtion
breaking into the capital because he
told them to go down there he said fight
peacefully he'd actually said go down
and fight like hell and then when they
did start fighting he did nothing until
it was too late stop politi have said
the terms fight like hell Republicans
and Democrats that is a fure of speech
many how many have stood there having
done that and watch rioting take place
and refuse to stop it until it's too
late he he acted on it as soon as he got
the White House come on he he didn't oh
come on he
didn't accusing Donald Trump of having
any involvement with January 6 and
turning a blinde to Nancy Pelosi being
speaker of the house having declined
extra security measures for the capital
that day at the request of President
Trump is then you're being a hypocrite
if you don't bring up Nancy Pelosi she
wanted the political theater she got the
political Fe she wanted a riot she
wanted a riot of oh come on then don't
be ridiculous saying Donald Trump had
anything to do with
it we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals using XL Bully dogs as weapons
to threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swear an off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it it's hard
to know whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by as to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pound so far so4 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for AIT if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which walks into a branch
of McDonald MC mous man MC mous man MC
man he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got a
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party just kids think all they have to
do is take pictures of everything just
shut down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
[Music]
that it's equally ridiculous I find it
bizarre that you don't think Donald
Trump has also told him a lot of a lot
of lies in his life I I just don't I
don't see it have you heard from him
since what happened no I have not do you
expect to I I he's busy he's running for
president I am he spends his life on the
phone I really hope I am not anywhere
near the top 100 issues of trump right
now because then I would be concerned
who who's bothered to call call you of
any I received calls from my colleagues
in Congress repeatedly I still have
great friends there I I talk to them I
was on before I came here was on the
phone with three of them we're on the
phone regularly I built Everlasting
relationships with people on both sides
of the aisle not just Republicans just
recently I was a Democrat out of Florida
calls me he's at a a mixer or whatever
and there was a couple of my
constituents there giving him a hard
time that he expelled me and he's like
look I have some of your supporters here
and they're mad at me a Democrat Donald
Trump was to win the election and he
might well the way the polls are going I
believe he will by a landslide if he did
and he he decided to to bring you out of
the coal would you would you accept what
does that mean well if he said to you
I've got some job in my Administration
for you I'd love to work might look at
you and think a young Dynamic gay
Republican all right he's flawed but so
am I all right he's done some bad stuff
so did I but I'm now back as president
I'm going to bring back George Santos
I'd put it out there I'd love to be ice
director if if was that serious thing
that's serious that's serious what would
you do if you were I speak four
languages I understand Logistics I'm
really good on my feet what would you do
if you were the ice it's very simple
it's it's about rest strategizing ice
first of all assuming that the president
would give ice its power back and
assuming that we can go ahead and Sue
into Oblivion all these Sanctuary
nonsense laws so that the federal
government can do its job here's the
problem with ice today ice has been
handicapped for decades at this point
nobody has ever Mak taken it serious but
I remember as a little boy 13 years old
being on the seventh train in New York
city that runs into Queens to Manhattan
and having ice stops those were common
right after 911 because they were
picking up bad people on the train now
why don't we bring that back I think
it's time we act New York City has
probably the largest propensity of
people living there with removals
proceed active removals proceedings
which means you have a deportation
mandate on you and they defy it and live
blatantly in the open there just with
the Joe Biden Administration Alone 10
million came in in three years there's
no way we have 12 million the situation
on the board ridiculous completely out
of control absolutely nonsense and Joe
Biden has shown no ability to my orcas
is even all my orcas is a dereliction of
Duty if you were to look up in a
dictionary dereliction of Duty it should
be Alejandro M oris's face in there now
I mean you talk of dereliction of Duty
do you think that you've been derilict
in your duty that's why you're sitting
here now because I served every single
day honorably I didn't do anything this
honorable while in Congress I voted
honorably I voted I the only votes I
missed was when I had court dates
couldn't control that GE You' been
facing 23 Federal criminal charges I've
been accused of only things before I was
elected nothing after I was elected I
have been accused of nothing during my
time as a member of Congress you told no
lies once you became a congressman I had
no reason to you can look at my record
and so what was the reason
before Pierce like I said no but I'm
curious I mean you said I had no reason
to what I'm what I'm try does beg the
question again what was reason before
okay so poor choice of words not reason
there was no need to lie or no no what a
need before again Pierce I can go back
and sayest with your own thoughts there
was no need but do we all control stupid
sometimes no stupid is stupid you do
stupid things and you can't control it
and you move past T the point I want I
want to make to you is that I can't help
liking you right there's something very
likable about you as a person I can't
help no a good friend that's what every
friend of mine ever told me well I yeah
so you have a lot of likable qualities
you're charismatic you're good on TV you
know you're clearly smart right you
clearly Got Deep
flaws if you do want to make a comeback
and it sounds to me like you absolutely
do the way you talk about potentially
running Ice May OB such a bad idea right
you lots of energy for it but if you
were to ever even be considered for that
you'd have to tell people and show
people that you changed and do you think
you're capable of that I'm doing it all
this year already throughout my actions
and and moving forward do you think the
the one thing the American people have
appreciated the most after I left
Congress is me not being afraid to just
call it like it is I saw the sausage be
made Pierce and now I just want to share
with everybody how the sausage is made
and why we are in the predicament we are
as a country people are what would your
mother have said to you about all l oh
she would have smacked me to hell oh my
god oh she was tough lady she did
physically smack you oh she would have
physically she would have physically
assaulted me why she it was unacceptable
what was everything the whole thing was
unacceptable even what would she have
found most egregious about your bab I I
would just say the fact that I had to
open my mouth and say anything that
wasn't true she would she would have
just beat me to her crisp she would have
pull pulled out a wooden stick you you
don't know that woman did you ever lie
to her oh I I I knew better than to do
that I knew better oh I definitely knew
better the one time I did I I caught a
beating but it was white little lie
where were you on my friend's house no
you weren't I went to and you weren't
there okay whoops so things teenagers do
nothing crazy does your father have the
same attitude to truth my father is the
most honest man you'll ever meet so this
is again fascinating to me you've got
two parents who sound like honesty is a
real premium to them honesty hard work
stay very big deal for both my do you
feel like you let them down
yes yes
do you miss your mother I it sounds like
she was hugely important to you
absolutely not a day goes by seven years
December 23rd that I lost my
mom seven years that feel like yesterday
you talk to herever I talk you know
you're going to call me crazy but yes
every day before I go to bed I I throw
some words up there and I hope she's
always listening what do you say I just
talk about whatever the day went or how
I'm feeling and just like part of my
prayers I believe it or not I'm actually
a Praying man still very much do you
think what would have do you think
what's happened to you would have
happened if she'd stayed alive
no no it would because you wouldn't have
been she would have guided me much
better she that was my compass right
there sad absolutely it's sad really
sad Pierce life is sometimes uh full of
uh twists and turns ups and downs and um
I'm not immune to it nobody's immune to
it we all go through it and um we all I
believe we all come back stronger from
controversy or from a situation like
this George if you end up going to
prison and obviously there's a
possibility you're facing very serious
charges if you do do you think you could
handle it I don't know Pierce have you
thought about it I I try not to think of
negatives like that I try to think as
positive as humanly possible um I'm 35
years old I trust the process
I I have not been somebody critical of
the doj unlike some other colleagues of
mine I I always have given organ our
organizations our entities FBI doj CIA
credibility because the moment I lose
faith in them I lose faith in this
entire country so but I I do trust the
process and I'm going to fight it what's
your biggest regret about the whole
thing I have many regrets what's your
biggest if I could do it all over again
I'd do it very differently what would
you do my my story is compelling as is
right as
is you remind me a little bit of um The
Wolf of Wall Street Jordan Belfor when I
interviewed him it's from my district
you didn't need to embellish your story
maybe uh the way I look at it is God had
intended a different path maybe that
that's the only thing I can say I I
believe in and I'm faithful so I believe
in there's always a reason why things
happen a certain way so maybe uh I was
destined to go do other things learn a
little bit about what's in there so I
can come out here and Open the Eyes of
the American people and maybe start a
revolution a political revolution that
we really have to have in this country
what's your final message for people
watching this don't count me out you
know
um I've given many people a second
chance and I'm asking everybody to
please give me a second chance and I
will you know come forward and prove to
be worth your second chance chance and I
just want people to look at that and and
say so many people uh make mistakes we
all make mistakes if you really take a
look deep inside and I I'm sorry and I I
look forward to continuing to to be a
voice for for those who seek uh
leadership in me George it's good to see
you again and I wish you all the very
best thank you very much whatever
[Music]
happens
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
to today we do it all sunak sella scon
I rather like David Cameron I don't sort
of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this Hammer
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadik Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking liit if you're walking towards
me and you're a vegan she have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC M man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was
after watching a Tom Cruz film